these healthcare workers are registering
to receive one of two vaccines approved
for use in
india three hundred thousand medical
professionals are being vaccinated at
three thousand sites around the country
on saturday
including kirin
i'm a little bit scared but i'm also
happy that we're being vaccinated first
i've been named as one of the first so
i'm happy about it and i want everyone
to get vaccinated
so we can end covered
government is planning to vaccinate 300
million people
in the first half of this year 30
million frontline workers
in healthcare sanitation the police the
army and disaster management will be
inoculated in the first few months
they'll be followed by people over the
age of 50
and then those under 50 with underlying
health conditions
prime minister miranda mori described
the scale of the program
there are more than 100 countries whose
population is less than 30 million and
india will be vaccinating
30 million people in the first phase of
vaccination itself
the drugs regulator has approved the use
of oxford astrazeneca's cover shield
vaccine
and one that's been made in india there
are questions around why
the indian vaccine by a local company
called bharath biotech was given
approval
when it hasn't finished its final phase
trials
the government has said that it will be
administered under clinical trial
conditions
but independent health experts say
there's not a lot of information
about what that means india is the only
country other than russia and china to
be administering a vaccine
that hasn't completed trials i think
that is probably causing a little bit of
concern among scientific circles and
also
sub-potential recipients that why was
that decision
expedited in such a way and should we
have waited a few weeks more
to get that data doctors at one of new
delhi's biggest government hospitals
have the same questions
they want the oxford astrazeneca vaccine
and not
bardot biotechs but india's health
minister says a lot of work had gone
into making the vaccines and people
cannot choose
which one they'll receive elizabeth
puranam al jazeera
new delhi